dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here
neural networks can be used to learn a
variety of things for instance to
classify images which means that we'd
like to find out what breed the dog is
that we see on the image this work uses
a combination of two techniques a neural
network variant that is more adapted to
the visual mechanisms of humans and is
therefore very suitable for processing
and classifying images this variant we
call a convolutional neural network
here's a great web application where you
can interactively train your own network
and see how it improves at recognizing
different things this is a data set
where the algorithm tries to guess which
class these smudgy images are from if
trained for long enough it can achieve a
classification accuracy of around 80
percent the current state of the art in
research is about 90 percent which is
just four percent off of humans who have
performed the same classification this
is already insanity we could be done
right here but let's put this on
steroids as you remember from an earlier
episode sentences are not one thing but
they are a sequence a sequence of words
therefore they can be created by
recurrent neural networks now I hope you
see where this is going
we have images as an input and sentences
as an output this means that we have an
algorithm that is able to look at any
image and summarize what is being seen
on the image buckle up because you're
going to see some wicked results it can
not only recognize the construction
worker it knows that he's in a safety
vest and is currently working on the
road it can also recognize that a man is
in the act of throwing a ball
a black and white dog jumps over a bar
it is not at all trivial for an
algorithm to know what over-and-under
means because it is only looking at a 2d
image that is the representation of the
3d world around us and there are of
course hilarious failure cases well a
baseball bat well close enough there is
a very entertaining web demo with the
algorithm and all kinds of goodies that
are linked in the description box check
them out the bottom line is that what we
thought was science fiction 5 years ago
is now reality in machine learning
research and based on how fast this
field is advancing we know that we're
still only scratching the surface thanks
for watching and I'll see you next time
oh and before you go you can now be a
part of two minute papers and support
the series on patreon a video with more
details is coming soon until then just
click on the link on the screen if
you're interested thank you